Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcasts UFO mit Stefftitz und Flo Will. Und heute hatten wir ein bisschen was überlegt, ein bisschen Konzept heute. Heute kommt die grosse Geständnis-Folge. Alexa, kaufe ein Fahrrad. Alexa, kaufe eine Jahrespackung Reese's Peanut Butter Cups. Alexa, unterstütze das Podcast UFO auf Patreon.com. Mit 100 Euro aufwärts. Bestelle 500 Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirts. Jetzt an. Die kann das sogar rückwärts. Okay, Google. Ich wollte nicht nur opfer. Aber Alexa kann das auch rückwärts. Also um euch mal kurz reinzubringen. Wir haben letztens über das neue Amazon Alexa gedöhnt, wo man Sprachanweisungen geben kann. Und ihr könnt uns nicht schreiben. Ihr könnt uns nicht sagen. Bitte sagt nie wieder Alexa. Das ist wie, als ob man einem Kind sagt, fass nie auf die Herdplatte. Da sind wir angefangen. Da sind wir zu frech dafür. Aber Alexa kann das auch rückwirkend. Wenn du sagst, wie hoch ist der Mount Everest, Alexa? Was mega gruselig ist, weil sie offensichtlich die ganze Zeit aufnimmt, nur halt gezögert wird, wenn man irgendwann mal das Wort Alexa benutzt. Aber du kannst ja aus jeder Situation treffen. Schatz, ich liebe dich nicht mehr, ich will dich verlassen. Alexa, kommst du immer noch mal raus und dann so, ne, ne, ne, ne, kannst du immer noch mal gut raus eigentlich. Es ging um Alkohol, heute geht es um Alkohol-Stories, wir wollten da immer richtig auspacken. Wann war Stefan Tingo das letzte Mal so richtig sturzknüllevoll, was ging los und wir haben uns an eine... Ey, wir haben uns echt erinnert, dass wir vor Maxi Stettenbauer die Folge, wo wir beide nervös waren, nicht wussten, wie er auf uns reagiert, zu Recht, wie sich nachher herausgestellt hat, wir dann im Neomagazin Ultrastress hatten den Tag und dann schnell aufgebaut haben, weil wir auch nicht mehr Zeit hatten und uns dann beide kurz am Kühltrank einem Eierlikörchen bedient haben. Naja, also, es war früher bei uns der Ritus, dass wir immer im Netto eingekauft haben, im Neomagazin, haben wir mittags immer im Netto eingekauft und es war so üblich Usus, dass wir uns gegenseitig geprankt haben und Sachen aufs Laufband mitgeschmuggelt haben, damit der andere Haha sich dann Feigling kauft und so. Ich wurde eines Tages gefoppt und hatte ab dann in meinem Besitz eine 0,8 Liter Flasche Eierlikör. Damals habe ich noch viele Schokobons gegessen und es hatte auch nur fünf K fünf Kilo Packung Schokobons, konnte man diese Flasche verstecken. Ja, ein Sack Schokobons. Kennst du das, dass du manchmal Dinge nur tust, weil du sie so aus Filmen kennst? Und dann dachte ich mir so, okay, stressiger Arbeitstag, gleich kommt Maxi Schettenbauer, ballere ich mir ein Eierlikör rein, obwohl ich das überhaupt rein körperlich nicht gebraucht habe. Ich dachte, das macht man so. So dieses so, fuck, ey, scheiße jetzt. Ich hätte auch Tabletten nehmen können. Da wären da so diese Pads rumgelegen. Ich hätte mir die wahrscheinlich wie so Tabletten in den Nacken geworfen. Einfach um dieses Aktual zu erfüllen. Ich habe das mal gemacht, weil ich das aus Filmen kenne und weil ich eine Flasche Whisky zu Hause habe. Und zwar für die mündliche Prüfung damals, die mündliche Präsentationsprüfung in der Uni. Und dann habe ich so ein, weil ich dachte, ich war ein bisschen nervös, da habe ich mir vorher so einen kleinen Whisky-Shot gegönnt und bin dann in die Uni gegangen damit und dann war die erste Frage, da muss man nämlich so ein Wisch unterschreiben, wo drauf ist, dass man gerade körperlich in der Verfassung ist, diese Prüfung zu halten und dann fragt er noch so, ja und wenn du was getrunken hast, oder hast du ja nicht? Und ich dachte mir, ich war die ganze Zeit mega nervös, hoffentlich merkte er das nicht, mein Gesicht war auch so rot, so warm, weil man halt, es wird einem so ein warmes Gefühl ums Herz dann auch, wenn man getrunken hat. Und dann war ich halt da und ich wollte das halt nicht so häufig und dann hat er gefragt, aber Sie haben ja nicht getrunken, oder? Und ich so, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, wie kommen Sie denn da auf, ha ha ha ha! Und dann habe ich aber diesen Wisch natürlich unterzeichnet, mein Eid quasi betrieben und dann, dann habe ich das gehalten, war ganz okay danach. Aber auch nur aus dem Film kennt. Total merkwürdig. Genau wie dieses Durchreissen von Handys, diesen Club-Handys. Ja, ja, ja. Diese Club-Handys, die gab es ja auch nur, weil man damit diese coole Geste machen konnte, dieses Durchbrechen und dann wegschmeißen konnte, als ob die dann nicht mehr gefunden werden können. Vor allem dann auf dem Polizeibüro dann zurücklassen. Ja gut, da ist das Display abgebrochen, aber wir können trotzdem die Daten noch retten. Die Festplatte ist noch ganz, die SIM-Karte ist noch ganz, es ist alles noch ganz. Manchmal teilweise, auch bevor ich zum Beispiel jemanden treffe und nervös bin und vor der Tür, mache ich auch nochmal so dieses Durchatmen, ohne dass ich es selber jetzt machen müsste unbedingt. Also irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, ich würde dann dem Protokoll folgen, einfach so, man macht das einfach so. Ich glaube, so werden auch einfach so Traditionen und Dinge einfach übertragen, ohne dass man weiß, woher das kommt. Ja, wenn ich Musik höre, denke ich immer, ich bin in so einer Collage, in so einer Filmcollage, wo gerade viele gute Dinge passieren. Dann höre ich immer so eine Musik, gehe morgens aus dem Haus, die Sonne strahlt mir entgegen und ich bleibe so kurz stehen, richte meinen Rucksack und gucke so sonneblinzend irgendwie in Richtung Himmel.
Ja, nicht in die Kamera gucken.
Nein, nein, die Kamera natürlich nicht, die ignoriere ich. Seid nicht dran vorbei, rieche noch meinen Rucksack, atem tief ein, spann den Rucksack noch mal so und laufe los zu der Musik. Und manchmal trete ich auch so Laub weg oder so, oder noch so eine Cola-Dose oder ein Stein, der da liegt, einfach weil es gut aussehen würde. Ja, und dann wirklich in Zeitlupe manchmal auch so ein bisschen, wenn dann irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, It's a mad world kommt und ich sitze dann da so und drehe dann auch so traurig, Arme verschränkt vor der Brust, drehe ich so traurig das Lauf weg und kick den Stein vor mir her, betrachte die Kinder wie sie mit Kreide auf die Straße malen. Aber was ich mir am häufigsten vorstelle, ist der Abspann. Die Kamera verfolgt mich so ein bisschen, zeigt mich von hinten, dann bleibt die Kamera stehen und ich laufe immer weiter in die Ferne und dann setzt die Musik ein, so der Abspann, aber ich laufe immer noch so weiter.
Das Schweigende Lämmer.
Sowas in der Richtung, ja. Und der Abspann läuft, ich stelle mir noch vor, genau wo die Schrift ist und so.
Und was steht denn so für einen Namen?
Stefan Tietze.
Autor Stefan Tietze, natürlich der Autor meines Lebens, bist natürlich, Stefan, das war klar. Apropos Autor deines Lebens. Sein voller Selbstbewusstsein reißt Stefan das Mikrofonstativ runter. So eine Scheisse hier immer. Jedes Mal ist es so eine Scheisse. Aber fahr ruhig vor mit der Story. Nee, nee, ich meine nur, wir haben uns auch echt zurückentwickelt. Also wir haben schon mal besser aufgenommen, wir hatten schon mal mehr Hörer, wir hatten schon mal bessere Gangs, unsere Hochphase ist vorbei. So, warum machen wir überhaupt noch weiter? Wir waren schon mal überall. Wir sind mittlerweile wie die Amigos, wir kündigen so eine Comeback an, obwohl wir nie wirklich zurückweg waren. Und so, man denkt auch, mach doch endlich Schluss, es reicht doch auch langsam.
Ja, aber das ist echt so ein Punkt, also wann, würden wir das mitkriegen, wenn wir jetzt wirklich den Shark jumpen, wenn wir wirklich jetzt so merken, es ist ja bei vielen Podcasts so, wo es 500 Folgen gibt, denke ich, sind auch 120, war alles gesagt. Würden wir das mitkriegen, würden unsere Zuschauer uns da drauf aufmerksam machen, zu sagen so, hey, ab jetzt ist gut? Ich glaube, es muss erst einen Podcast geben, der uns ablöst.
Also nicht gestern ist der Geisterbahn, der sich ablöst,
sondern wirklich Leute, die unser Alter haben,
die auch nur zu zweit sind, die ähnliche Rollenaufteilung haben.
Die gleichen Gags machen wir.
Genau, ähnlich sprechen, ähnlich medienreferentiellen Bullshit labern.
Ich glaube, dann merken wir das,
und dann können wir grün gewissens auch sagen, wir lassen es jetzt sein.
Aber ich glaube, dieses Jahr wird noch mal,
machen wir noch mal den grossen Abschied.
Vielleicht kommt dieses Jahr noch mal ein unvorhergesehenes Ereignis.
Okay, und dann waren wir bei Maxi Stettenbaum und dann haben wir uns beide, du hast mir das dann erzählt, dass du dir kurz ein Lütten gegönnt hast, ein kleines Eierlikörchen vom Tag. Weil du kannst ja Eilikör auch nicht so wegkippen, wie so ein Don Draper seinen Whisky.
Meeting beendet, so wegkippen und zack, so ein Eilikör ist ja sehr dickflüssig, du kannst nur so oder nubbelst du dich so mit deiner Zunge so wie so eine Katze falsch herum, wie so ein Wellen sind. Ja genau, das ist sehr gut gesagt, so aus der Öffnung raus, also lächerlich, ich habe seitdem und davor nie wieder Eilikör getrunken, weil es auch grässlich ist. Und da hast du mir eben verraten, dass du bei einer Story, also bei einer Folge tatsächlich getrunken hast. Ich war bei einer Folge, wo wir Skype aufgenommen haben, war ich angetrunken. Ich möchte die sehr intimen privaten Hintergründe davon nicht erläutern, aber es war so, dass ich wirklich brutal schlecht drauf war. Die Kina-Schoko-Freshe waren alle oder so ein Scheiß. Das war so abgelaufen, ja. Ich war so brutal schlecht drauf, dass ich mir dachte, ich komme jetzt nicht durch diese Folge durch und habe dann das gemacht, was ich dachte, dass Menschen machen in der Situation. Ich habe mir einen kleinen Whisky-Lütten geholt. Ich war auch natürlich nicht betrunken so, aber ich bin dafür, dass es mir sehr schlecht ging, ganz gut durch die Folge gekommen. Also nach der Folge dachte ich mir so, hey cool, du bist wirklich ein emotionsloses Stück Stein innen, du kannst, wenn du willst, einfach nach außen alles projizieren, was du willst. Ich denke mir aber auch die ganze Zeit, ich bin so emotionslos, ich habe keine Emotionen, ausser die Emotion Begeisterung, das ist das einzige Emotion, die ich habe, alle anderen so, ich habe immer, ich würde mich als wahnsinnig glücklich bezeichnen, ich bin einfach standardmäßig glücklich, ein bisschen immer unzufrieden, aber ich habe keine seltenen Downs wirklich hier, seltenen krasse Peaks nach unten, sondern eher krasse Peaks nach oben, die mich in den Ruin treiben. So war es bei mir auch, aus eigener Erfahrung fühlst du dich jetzt emotional immun, du denkst, okay, mich kann nichts hart treffen, aber wenn dann mal was kommt, was dich richtig kaputt macht, wie es bei mir war, dann ist es umso schlimmer, weil du immer dachtest, du hast keine Coping-Mechanisms gelernt. Wenn jemand, der zweimal im Monat richtig schlecht drauf ist und rumheult, der kann mega gut damit umgehen, aber so Leute wie wir die Steine sind einfach, die dann einfach sagen, ja, ist ja kein Problem, schau ich mir einfach die nächste Staffel True Detective an, das passt dann schon. Und wenn dann aber mal was kommt, wenn dann mal irgendwie Stacey URico nicht auf deinen Brief antwortet, dann legst du richtig am Boden und dann bist du kaputt. Wann hast du das letzte Mal geweint? Wann hast du das letzte Mal so richtig geweint? Also ich meine, richtig geweint, einfach wo du dann auch nicht mehr richtig sprechen kannst, weil du so dann auch die Atmung dann so einsetzt, weil du wirklich weinst einfach, nicht nur ein Tränchen im Film oder so, die Wange runterkullert. Das ist schon, das war glaube ich zu einer ähnlichen Zeit als diese Down-Folge.
Bei mir war das noch nicht so lange her.
Also bei Filmen halt manchmal, aber das ist halt dann nicht so richtiges Schluchzen, sondern halt so, man verdrückt so eine Träne so, aber das glaube ich zählt jetzt nicht dazu.
Bei mir war es nicht lange her und es ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm, das zu verraten.
Rogue One?
Ne, es ist ein ähnlicher Kontext, als Carrie Fisher gestorben ist. Nein, ernsthaft? Das ging mir richtig nah. Das ging mir richtig nah. Da hast du geweint? Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Aber ich war im Restaurant, als ich diese Nachricht gelesen habe, und ich war echt ein bisschen perplex. Und zu Hause war ich geweint. Weil es tat mir so leid, weil so eine verletzbare Frau, das ging mir richtig nah. das war wie so eine Mutter, die einen so oft glücklich gemacht hat, die einen so oft begleitet hat an schlechten Tagen, an verregneten Sonntagen und so und die immer die tolle sympathische Prinzessin war und die so viel Zeit ihres Lebens gewidmet hat, einen glücklich zu machen eigentlich und dann, dass sie plötzlich, obwohl sie noch so gut drauf war und immer so lustige Interviews gegeben hat. Ich liebe Menschen, die lustige Interviews geben, die lustige Persönlichkeiten sind, die man gerne sieht, wenn sie auftauchen. Auf Bilde, meinst du? Auf Bilde und Promiflash, finde ich super. Und dann ist sie einfach gestorben, aus dem Nichts. Und beziehungsweise, da war ja vorher, ging es wieder besser und so. Es kam so plötzlich für mich, dann habe ich dazu John Williams' Princess Theme gehört, aber ich musste wirklich weinen. einfach krasser. Das war bei mir auch so, dass ich schlecht drauf war. Aber erst als ich ein passendes Lied angemacht habe, da muss ich wirklich weinen. Musik macht viel. Aber man gibt sich dann selbst auch so ein bisschen Rahmen. Weil es hat ja durchaus was Reinigendes, sich so richtig auszuheulen. Ja, das war's immer auch. Dass der so richtig die Botschaft von Inside Out ist, was ein toller Film ist, wo ich wahrscheinlich auch geweint habe. Da habe ich an manchen Stellen einfach geweint. Aber ich glaube, das zählt nicht bei Filmen. Das funktioniert nicht. Das ist auch ein bisschen Cheaten mit John Williams und so an. Vielleicht wollte ich ja auch da weinen. Aber mich hat es auch ein bisschen fertig gemacht, dass die ganzen Leute dann geschrieben haben, 2016, jetzt nicht auch noch Carrie Fisher, wo ich mir denke, reduzierst du nicht das scheiß Jahr? Das ist schlimm einfach. Das ist furchtbar, das zu sagen. Das ist furchtbar, zu sagen, danke 2016. Oder das aufs danke 2016 oder das aufs ja zu schieben anstatt einfach zu sagen das ist eine Zeitung hat diesen Satz gebracht dass sie strangled by her own bra gestorben ist was sie sich immer gewünscht hat wenn sie stirbt dann sollen Leute schreiben she died in the moonlight strangled by her own bra und dann haben das alle Zeitungen geschrieben, genau so und das fand ich, das ist schon cool, das ist schon cool, das ist schon cool, das ist schon cool, da muss ich, heute ist die emotionalen Folge, ja, absolut, was möchtest du denn, dass in den Zeitungen entsteht, wenn du stirbst, das ist eine gute Frage, ne, ich habe mir eigentlich gedacht, tatsächlich, um auf eine andere Frage zu antworten, ist ja häufig so, dass, angenommen, ich würde sterben, so ihr würdet alle gute Arbeit, neben dem Magazin, würde alles nochmal weiterlaufen, weil ihr alle sagen würdet, Stefan hätte es so gewollt, um hier ein für alle Mal zu sagen, nein, ich will, dass ihr alle in den Ruin geht, ich will, dass du diesen Podcast, nein, ich will nicht, dass du ihn weitermachst, ich will, dass du ihn begräbst. Ich habe mir wirklich schon mal Gedanken darüber gemacht, was passiert, wenn du stirbst, ob ich dann noch, ob ich dann einfach sage, okay, Podcast UFO war es das, oder ob ich nochmal eine Folge machen soll, in der ich nochmal sage, hey, ja, ihr wisst ja alle, Stefan, hat es erwischt, irgendwie bei seinem Boosted-Board-Unfall auf der A8, er war komplett Eierlikör besoffen, er hat komplett irgendwie Leitplange gewickelt, was bei Stefan merkt, das habe ich letztens gemerkt, wir hatten gedreht, haben wir nachts gedreht, und Stefan ist nach 22 Uhr einfach betrunken, ohne dass er Alkohol zu sich genommen hat. Du bist einfach die geborene Partymaus, du bist einfach eine sehr günstige Partymaus. Wenn ich Alkohol trinke, werde ich ruhiger am Abend. Ich werde ruhiger, besonnener, nicht unbedingt glücklicher und aufgeschlossener, sondern ich werde halt quasi, also wenn ich trinke, bleibe ich normal. Wohingegen wenn ich nichts trinke, wenn ich ich Zitat Stefan, diese wenn ich trinke, bleibe ich normal. Ansonsten greifen die Dämonen nach mir. Okay. Ja, aber was ich damit sagen will, ich werde dann halt nachts so, ich werde so Müdigkeit trunken und Kälte trunken, auch ein sehr kalter Dreh nachts, und dann werde ich einfach so glücklich und die Endorphine versuchen, was gegen die Situation zu tun, Und dann glaube ich, werde ich einfach so ein Müdigkeitstrunk. Das war ganz merkwürdig. Stefan hat richtig angefangen zu lallen und konnte sich kaum noch bewegen irgendwie. Und er macht ja sonst auch nicht die beste körperliche Figur. Und es war sehr grotesk anzusehen, wie der dieser Mensch irgendwie rumeiert. Was ist denn hier los? Plötzlich, also das war wirklich nicht weit von Washington entfernt. Ich laufe, wenn man ab und zu mal so Programmierer sieht, die Tests machen, um Roboter zu testen, wie die richtig gehen, aber dann so irgendwie ein Bein aus Spaß ein bisschen kürzer machen und dann das Ding erst so ein bisschen geht in der Simulation und dann einfach umfällt so ungeschenkt. So laufe ich dann nachts. Ja, wie so die ersten vier Tests von Gollum. Oder so wie Gollum läuft und dann irgendwie völlig umfällt. Umfällt und so die Beine ineinander schlingen. Umknickt und so, so sah Stefan aus. Für mich ist, glaube ich, eine gute Analogie sind so diese Faultiere, die halt so langsam sich bewegen und dann halt einen, den Arm für den Ast halten, sich an einem eigenen Arm festhalten, das merken, aber zu langsam, um noch was ändern zu können und dann langsam in den Tod st stürzen. Was ich sagen wollte, ich glaube, wenn Leute irgendwann behaupten, Stefan hätte es so gewollt, dass wir weitermachen damit. Nein, das ist eine Lüge. Ich will, dass ihr alle in den Ruinen geht und einfach aufhört damit. Also gute Arbeit soll begraben werden, die Magazin soll begraben werden, alles soll begraben werden. Das ist hart, wenn du jetzt sagst, wenn ich sterbe, soll die Magazin enden, und dann stirbst du, und dann steht, also niemand, natürlich würde es niemand beenden. Nein, aber alle finden sich zumindest ein bisschen schlecht und das will ich auslösen, das Gefühl. Du musst ein ganzes Testament hinterlassen, dass man einfach weiß genau, was er gewollte. Ich vermache auch Dinge Leuten, die ich gar nicht besitze. Ja, die die dann auftreiben müssen. So, ich schenke Leuten das Studio hier einfach. Das kann ich nicht. Technisch gesehen ist es jetzt in deinem Besitz. Stefan hat es hier vererbt. Ich glaube, ich würde einfach aus den ganzen Podcast-Üvo-Folgen
so ein Audiotestament zusammenschnippeln,
aus dem dann irgendwie sehr geht.
Hallo, ich möchte diesen Baum.
Hallo, ich kriege mein ganzes Geld.
Busselbort nicht.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Ein Rap, der so viel auch ein Rap ist.
Ja, Stefan konnte sich vor allem durch Raps sehr ausdrücken.
Ja, also das war, aber gab es so Folgen, wo du so richtig, also da gab es wahrscheinlich diese eine Folge, wo du so richtig down warst und einfach dann was trinken wolltest. Da war ich richtig kaputt und es ging aber einigermaßen. Weil ich aus Filmen gelernt habe. Ihr könnt ja jetzt mal raten, welche Folge das war, in der es mir so schlecht ging. Wo du davor so ein Whisky eigentlich. Wo ich mir davor, vor allem, ich hatte mal gehört, ich habe keine Ahnung von Alkohol und habe nur mal gehört, dass man Whisky Sour trinkt, Whisky mit Zitronensaft und habe dann, ich als Anfänger, der noch nie auch nur ein Bier in meinem Leben davor getrunken habe, habe ich dann Whisky mit Zitronensaft und es hat so grässlich geschmückt, wie Terpentin mit irgendwie einem Klostein drin, das habe ich grauenvoll einfach. Weil einfach das Gefühl hat, das ist grauenvoll, das ist schrecklich, mir ging es noch schlechter danach als davor. Das war wirklich furchtbar. Aber es ging, aber es war gut zu merken, weil ich glaube, mich war es nicht sogar auch Maxi Stettenbauer, der gesagt hat, ey, wenn du Stand-Up-Comedian bist, wenn deine Mutter stirbt, musst du am selben Abend noch auf die Bühne und performen. Könnte auch. Könnte auch Richard Pryor gewesen sein. Ich bin mir nicht 100% sicher. War es der große Maxi Stettenbauer? To go to Maxi Stettenbauer. Erfolgen musst du einfach nicht. Das ist einfach eine Lüge. Nein, musst du nicht. Nee, ist sehr einfach aufzusagen. Alle verstehen sofort. Instant, ja. Wir müssen Maxi Stettenbauer noch mal einladen. Wir haben ihn mal auf dem Comedypreis gesehen und haben mit uns gesprochen. Und wir haben gesagt, hey cool, wir können noch mal eine zweite Aufnahme machen oder so, hätte er Bock drauf und ich glaube, das müssen wir machen. Wir müssen da mal ein bisschen altes Blut schöpfen und so und das ist einfach, glaube ich, dass wir uns versöhnen hier in der Comedy-Szene. Wir haben in letzter Folge eine Rubrik angefangen, dass wir Tipps geben, Lebensratschläge geben. Ich weiß nicht, du wolltest dir einen überlegen, hast du es getan? Ja. Denkst du den jetzt aus. Richtig. Viel Spaß mit Florian Draschelag. Um den Dreck unter euren Fingernägeln zu entfernen, faltet einfach ein Blatt Papier zweimal in der Mitte und reinigt mit der Kante die Fingernägel. Und reisst euch die Fingerkuppen ab. Die Fingernägel, das ist nämlich weich, zart und fest zugleich und Papier ist überall verfügbar. Papier in die Fingernägel reinstecken oder was? Du knickst das Papier und dann nochmal, so dass du dann eine richtig dicke Ecke hast. Und damit ist dann so ein Schaufel-Effekt, kannst du den Dreck unter den Fingernägeln rausschaufeln, weil du hast immer, Papier ist immer zur Hand und es ist auch tatsächlich recht schonend, weil es nicht so hart ist wie eine Feile. Oder nimmt ein Gitarren-Prum. Oh, da kommt der Musiker. Wir wollten, wann das eigentlich endlich die Folge, Stefan sperrt sich da schon seit Monaten davon. Ich muss mir die ganzen Anekdoten nochmal ausdenken. Nochmal abgleichen mit allen anderen Weltmitgliedern. Was habt ihr erzählt? Wie viele Groupies haben wir flachgelegt? 70, ne? Wir können uns nicht unterscheiden. Ja, das ist wichtig, dass wir da nochmal kurz in die Recherche gehen. Das ist doch ein cooler Sketch. So eine Gruppe Freunde trifft
sich, noch fünf Jahre, nachdem sie
irgendwas erlebt haben. Alle haben
massiv andere Vorstellungen, von dem was passiert ist.
Und zetteln so die Fakten. So, hey, wir erzählen diese
Storys seit fünf Jahren. Es kamen schon
zu ein paar momentanen Schwierigkeiten.
Wir müssen heute einfach mal
unsere Story straight kriegen.
Was ist genau passiert? Und dann überlegen sie, wie sie übertreiben sollen. Wo war das Plektrum-Debakel, das grosse Plektrum? In Fürth oder in Rödlingen? In Rödl-Lüdl-Ded. Also hier entstehen neue Ideen. Irgendwas Idee, ich hatte mal eine App-Idee, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal gepitcht habe, aber dass man eine App macht. Steffans App-Ideen. Eine Fitness-App und das ist eine Standard-Fitness-App, so ein Sieben-Minuten-Workout gibt es ja auch, wo man schnell einfach so Zirkeltraining macht, so ein bisschen für sich in der Wohnung auch gern. Aber wenn man nicht trainiert einen Tag, bezahlt man ein Euro an die App. Heißt, Leute haben natürlich den Drive.
Leute müssen es durchhalten, weil sie sonst verarmen.
Ich glaube, die meisten laden sich das runter, weil sie es eine lustige Idee halten,
machen das dann einen Tag, sind genervt, weil sie es vergessen haben und einen Euro bezahlt haben,
löschen sich die App instant.
Aber ich glaube, damit...
Aber kann man nicht einfach bescheissen und sagen, man hätte trainiert, ohne dass man trainiert hat?
Ja, muss man daran denken.
Also mir ist es als App-Entwickler komplett egal, ob die Leute abnehmen oder nicht. Aber letzten Endes drückst du einmal pro Tag auf so einen Button, ich habe heute trainiert. Ja, weil wenn du das einmal einer vergisst, krieg ich einen Euro instant. Es werden 10.000 vergessen nach meiner ersten Kalkulation, die ich mit Excel erstellt habe. Ich glaube, das ist eine, nach der Gauschen-Normalverteilung glaube ich, vergessen. Aber wäre es ja nicht besser, wenn du ein Euro kriegst, wenn du trainierst? Na, dann kannst du auch einfach bescheissenen. Du kannst immer einfach bescheißen. Es gibt eine App, wo man, glaube ich, am Anfang eine sehr grosse Summe bezahlt und dann je pro getanener Arbeit ein bisschen Geld zurückbekommt. Warum ist das cleverer? Nee, das ist cleverer, weil man denkt, ja klar zahle ich jetzt 100 Euro, weil ich werde jetzt vier Jahre lang jeden Tag trainieren, dann zahlst du 100 Euro und denkst dir, ja, das Geld hole ich wieder rein nach 100 Tagen. Das ist eine viel zu grosse Summe. Nee, aber du denkst dir, das Geld hole ich wieder rein nach 100 Tagen und dann mache ich Profit. So denkt nämlich jeder, kauft sich die App, hört nach 12 Tagen auf zu trainieren und man hat 88 Euro verdient als App-Hersteller. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee. Ich stelle mir gerade so einen Channel vor, so Mathematik-Tipps, der sich immer unsere Folgen anhört und dann so Ausschnitte zeigt, ja hier hat Plotin diesen klassischen Fehler gemacht, dass man im Kopf einfach dann auch falsch rechnet. Man hat immer so Mathefehler auseinander. Das ist eigentlich mein, ich möchte gerne Negativbeispiel sein. Ja. Ich will das Vorherbild sein. Ja, oder Nachherbild nach einem Auton. Das personifizierte Vorherbild. Vorherbild oder Nachherbild nach einem Autonfall. Ja, oder so nach Rauchen oder Math. Math-Adict. Richtig, ja. Entweder das nachher oder das vorher. Ich bin immer genau die falschen Vorher und Nachher, die man nicht sein will. Du bist das, was man nicht sein will, ja. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht mal machen. Entwickelt das mal da draußen jemand, können wir das mit der großen Pufo-Enterprise kann das dann vermarkten. Ey, wir haben mittlerweile ein bisschen Geld zusammengetragen auf Patreon.com und können damit natürlich auch eure App-Ideen unterstützen. Wir machen so eine Höhle des Löwen, finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Mal für nächste Folge, ballert mal eure App-Ideen raus und wir suchen uns die beste aus und unterstützen die. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Wir hauen Zwanni raus. 20.000? Nee, Zwanni, ihr könnt, genau, wir machen ein Gewinnspiel. Zwanni, wir ballern nächste Woche in Zwanni raus für die beste App-Ideen. Schon 200 oder nicht? Hey, das ist ein bisschen zu wenig. Ja, aber die Leute sollen nicht wissen, dass wir so viel Geld haben, dass wir... Ja, aber wir können, wenn wir... Wir haben einen hohen achtstelligen Betrag. Ja, aber wenn wir einfach so 200 Euro rausballern, dann denken wir heute, mein Gott, wie viel Geld müssen wir haben, dann spenden die weniger auf Patreon. Ja, aber die können doch nicht ahnen, dass wir so einen hohen achtstelligen Betrag eingeladen haben. Ja, aber wenn wir 200 Euro einfach so mindestens nichts rausballern, dann denken die, wir haben so viel Geld. Okay. Also wir kriegen einen Zwanny. Ja. Und damit unterstützen wir euch. Ohne Scheiß, wir machen das wirklich. Ihr kriegt einen Zwanny, um eure App-Idee umzusetzen. Ja, aber ihr müsst ihr dann um... Also wir sind natürlich die Mitverdiener. Klar. Wir kriegen auch jeweils 33 Prozent. Klar, logisch. Ja. Unterstützen euch mit einem Zwanny, kaufen uns, und ihr kümmern euch aber darum, dass die umgesetzt wird und dass sie die verkaufen. Swanny in Podcast-Supportitiers kriegt natürlich dann vorbei. Ja, geil, mal gucken, wie viel Innovation in der Podcast-Community steckt. Ich glaube, wir hatten bestimmt schon mal Gewinnspiel, aber auch nie die Seite gelöscht. Folge Server-Error, schade. Pinguine sind monogam. Monogam bedeutet, dass sie nur einen Pinguin essen dürfen. Oder was? Ja, also die haben ein Leben lang nur einen einzigen Partner. Könnte ich mir nicht vorstellen. So, jetzt mal kurz eine Frage. Wer hat das rausgefunden? Eine ganz einfache Frage. Wer hat das rausgefunden? Ein Typ mit einem Edding. Das Pinguine. Ein Mensch mit einem dicken Edding, mit einem Edding, Pfeil und Bogen. So ein pinken Sprüff. Einfach mal ganz kurz. Mit einem pinken Pfeil und Bogen. Da kommen also die Pinguine so. Willst du mich heiraten? Ja. Zipp aus dem Nichts kommt ein Edding. Tot. und bemalt ihn einfach so, bemalt und dann so, das krieg ich nicht mehr weg. Wenn ihr jetzt Schluss macht, weil die dann den Geruch verfälschen oder so? Ja, Pinguine sind monogam oder können sehr gut fremdgehen. Das hat einfach noch nie jemand rausgefunden, weil die einfach mega sneak sind, die auch so falsche Nachrichten und die Uhrzeit verstellen über den Nachrichten und so, die sind mega clever.
Die sehen halt auch alle gleich aus, das war der eigentliche Gag.
Und deswegen
dachte ich mir, vielleicht hat dann irgendwer so gefallen.
Und, was ist eigentlich rausgekommen
bei der monatelangen Arktis, Antarktis,
keine Ahnung, Reise, so was ist da passiert,
sind sie das Monogam oder nicht?
Und der einfach improvisiert hat und gesagt hat,
er war sehr weit weg auf dem Gang,
auf einem anderen Gebäude, die Gebäude waren so mit einer Strasse getrennt.
Und, ist er monogam? Ja, danke, wie geht es der Familie? Schreibt sie in die Wikipedia, monogam, nicht monogam, monogam, erlöscht das andere weg. Ja, aber jetzt mal unter uns. Wen interessiert das denn? Also sorry, ich meine, wir haben einen Job, dessen gesellschaftlich relevant ist, gegen negative Werte strebt. Aber ob jetzt Pinguine monogam sind oder nicht, who the fuck cares? Also klar, cool, wenn dir das interessiert und so, aber also ich glaube, wie ist das Selbstverständnis von den Leuten, die sowas rausfinden, gehen die nachts ins Böde und denken, ja, jetzt habe ich, der Wikipedia von Pinguinen ist jetzt zwei Zeilen länger. Ich schlaf ruhig. So, das passiert auch nicht. Noch schlimmer finde ich die, die dann die Diskussionen entfachen bei der Wikipedia-Seite und dann aktiv daran arbeiten wollen, ob das stimmt oder nicht und infrage stellen, wo soll die da reinschreiben. Noch schlimmer als die, die reinschreiben, der ist monogam, finde ich diejenigen, die infrage stellen, ja, wo haben sie das denn rausgefunden? Ist er wirklich monogam, die das nicht akzeptieren können? Wir haben ja diese Beweisfotos, sie ist bei ihrer Wohnung und sie läuft an der Wohnung der anderen heißen Pinguin-Frau vorbei. So ein Pinguin, der mit seinen Autoschlüsseln vor so einem Auto steht und es nicht aufbekommt. Wir haben ihn da gesehen. Ja, und dann so diese ganzen Chatprotokolle und sowas. Aber auch so, da habe ich so einen Radiobeitrag gehört über Zugvögel, wo auch so ein scheiß Typ, so ein Moderator. Von Florentin. Florentins Funfreizeit. Hat drei Zugvögelexperten in der Leitung, drei. Und die haben sich auch so ein bisschen untereinander gestritten. Aber die haben dann auch so gesagt, so ja, und die haben dann gesagt, so ja, und wie ist es denn, landen denn die Zugvögel auch ab und zu oder fliegen die straight durch? Da meinte einer so, ja, das können wir nicht so hundertprozentig beobachten, weil da fehlen uns so ein bisschen die Forschungsgelder und die Mittel. Wir würden da gerne mehr Teams zusammenstellen, um das rauszufinden und der Moderator eigentlich so ununterschwellig so, ja, aber eigentlich ist es auch scheißegal. Also eigentlich so, ja, ja, oder wir bauen ein Krankenhaus. Okay, das, jetzt kommen die Rolling Stones. Und nächste Woche sogar die Leute vom Kinderhauspitz. Jetzt viel Spaß mit Bobbinden. Ja, uns fehlt Geld. Ja, also wir haben jetzt mehr Forschungsgelder für die Grafen bekommen und können jetzt rausfinden, wie viele ihrer Hufe sie eigentlich mit dem Paarungstanz verwenden. Cool, cool. Ja, immer noch für die Weisen. Wow, das sind gut angelegte 10.000 Euro und jetzt viel Spaß mit den Droning-Stats. Der Kinderhospiz-Chor bittet um ihre Spenden. Oh Gott, ein Kinderhospiz-Chor grauenvoll. Ja. Funke, Funke, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,useum, geil, große Bibliothek, geil, Saturn, Saturn, kann ich den Kaufhof. Andere Seite, Brachland, Mordor, verbrannte Erde, überall, tote Bäume, so verschiedene Skelette laufen durch die Gegend.
Und da hatte ich Gesangsunterricht. Ich musste immer aus der falschen Seite raus, muss man sich auch mal bekreuzigen, sonst stirbt man instant. Dann bin ich weiter gelaufen, weiter in die Hölle rein. Und irgendwo war dann da halt diese Künstlerin, diese wahnsinnig renommierte Gesangslehrerin, Die hat mitten in der Dortmunder Nordstadt einfach ihre Praxis, nenne ich es jetzt mal, hatte, wo man dann reingegangen ist.
Und oft war ich noch, also anfangs war ich noch ganz klein, da hat mich mein Vater immer gebracht und der hat dann immer gewarnt, da draußen die dreiviertel Stunde mit seinem Auto und hat mich dann wieder mitgenommen auf dem Rückweg. Er hat dann einfach drei, vier Stunden draußen verbracht und hat dann immer den Leuten dazugeguckt und hat nicht selten einfach krasse Drogendelikte beobachtet, was einfach eine krasse Gegend ist.
Und dann hatte ich Gesangsunterricht in einer Privatwohnung, die war relativ klein, wo einfach ein Klavier dann so im Wohnzimmer stand. Und da habe ich dann geträllert, was das ganze Haus mitbekommen hat. Und ich stelle mir vor, das waren halt nur Schwerverbrecher, Mörder, Kinderschänder, Gesangsunterricht, Mörder, Mörder. Und irgendwo zwischendrin hat halt so ein Junge gelernt, wie man okay singt. Und das war halt dazwischen, was immer ein bisschen befremdlich war, weil ich am Anfang nicht getraut habe, laut zu singen, weil es hat locker irgendjemand, der sich gerade so ein Messer an so einem Schleifstein irgendwie schärft. Der sein Schwertschleif. Ja, und das war echt immer ganz spannend, das lagen auch oft einfach Menschen im Treppenhaus und so und das war halt mitten da da drin. Aber mit welchem Alter hast du angefangen? Weiß ich nicht, 13, 14? 13 und dann bis wann? 18. Fünf Jahre lang Gesangsunterricht? Ja. Krass. Vielleicht ein bisschen später angefangen, aber ja. Nicht schlecht. Bis 18. Und dann Binky-Sack-Buck-Karriere. Ja, nee, das fing da parallel war das schon. Und dann habe ich auch in zwei Musicals mitgesungen, drei Musicals. Krass. Cool, das ist ziemlich cool. Ich war so ein klassischer Mobbing-Opfer in so College-Filmen, so Highschool-Filmen, immer der uncoole Typ aus der Musical-AG. Ja, aber die Moral am Ende ist dann, dass er als einziger erfolgreich ist und alle anderen unglücklich. Ja, aber das war eine wilde Zeit in Dortmund und in Nordstadt. Du hast so mal Gitarrenunterricht. Ich hatte Gitarrenunterricht, ja, ist richtig. Langsam haben wir so ein Deutschlandradioniveau erreicht. Ja, ist richtig. Sie hatten lange Gitarrenunterricht und für ihr neues Album, da kam der Habicht eine Minute zu spät. Hört man davon ein bisschen was? Sie haben die Gitarre nochmal ausgepackt. Ich habe die Gitarre ausgepackt, natürlich, sie war ein bisschen eingestaubt. Aber die klang noch gut, die klang nach Kindheit, das hat mir immer viel gegeben. Jetzt haben Sie mit dem Belgischen Hafenorchester tatsächlich eine Menge, eine Menge Ruhm geerntet. Speziell im Baltikum waren Sie sehr unterwegs. Wo ist Ihnen da am besten gefallen?
Wir waren da in einem Hotel in Balausana und das ist ganz direkt an den Schwarzalpen gelegen. Und da hatten wir auch eine Zusammenkunft mit einem Bärenweibchen tatsächlich, da sind wir rausgegangen. Wir wollten Picknick machen, Karna Nawacek, meine, ja, mit Komponistin und Dirigentin, Sopranistin und, ja, Freundin, Hafenspielerin hat sie jetzt bei dem Arrangement nicht mitgespielt, aber privat ist sie noch eine ganz fantastische Arrangement. Ja, gerade auf dieses Arrangement wollte ich mal zu sprechen kommen. Peter Manischek hat es komponiert im Alter von 23 Jahren und hat es auch arrangiert und dann selber später auch mit ihrem Hafenorchester dann auch mal die Welturaufführung in Bern. In Bern, genau, das war im Konzerthaus von Manfred Watzlaw und das war natürlich auch eine Uraufführung. Das ist wie eine Geburt. Und da gab's den Skandal, da gab's den grossen Skandal der ...
Möchten Sie sich selber ausführen? Also rückblickend ist es natürlich schon immer schwierig, gerade mit den Sicherheitsbestimmungen, die dann natürlich auch oft bei den ganzen Hafen. Also wir hatten immer die Frage, diese 460 Hafen, wie bringen wir die ins Gemeindehaus? Und klar, da müssen Brandwälder weg, da müssen Feuerlöscher weg.
Es wurde Bern quasi brandgerodet um den Weg für die Harfen. Da gab es das Problem, dass die Bibergebiete durchschnitten worden sind.
Rückblickend gab es da viel Ärger, auch mit den grossen Umweltorganisationen.
Interessanterweise hat sich im Nachhinein herausgestellt, dass diese Harfenmusik auf einer Interfrequenz stattfindet, die für die Biber sehr irritierend ist und die sich auch zu dem Feuer haben hinziehen lassen.
Die sind dann alle verbrannt.
Paarungsrichtig, die sind alle, ja gut, die Glücklichen sind verbrannt, die Unglücklichen waren natürlich unter dem Schwelbrand natürlich Gefangenen, auch stundenlang.
Und das hat auch die Geräusche, die die von sich gaben, hat natürlich dann auch eine ganz interessante Harmonie mit reingebracht. Ja, vor allem das Konzert war ja dann relativ erfolgreich dann dennoch. Leute waren begeistert, das Feuilleton war begeistert. Die Toten, die Todesopfer haben viel Erfolg überschattet, was ich im Nachhinein bereue. Vielen Dank, das war Herbert Brandschlaff vom Hafenorchester Neuwied. Und der nächste Gast ist noch nicht da. Deswegen erst mal Musik von Bernhard Briegel, der jetzt in seine neue Nasenflöte zeigt, der neues Album Der Stuhl auf dem Flur mit dem Pferd auf der Wiese. In zwei Ländern schon bereits aufgeführt worden. Und das läuft dann im Cut-to-go immer auf ...
Die ganze Zeit.
Auf Low-Jacket 99 läuft dann im car to go immer auf die ganze zeit auf laus jacket 99 läuft dann die nasen-u-opa von brunzmann brieselkrank und dann sitzt du im auto und denkst was ist eigentlich hier los furchtbar grüßt du andere car to go fahrer in ihren autos wie ein busfahrer ja ja immer so grüssend aber abfällig auch so. Also ich will was Besseres sein, ich will eigentlich Drive Now fahren, aber es ist mir noch zu teuer, aber ich will es nicht zugeben. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich habe letztens jemanden gesehen, ich hatte eine Packung Skittles, grüne Skittles in der Hand, die mich schön reingekippelt, ja ui ui ui, da würde ich gar nicht aufmachen. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich, da war ich am Bahnhof und dann bin ich so entlanggeschlendert, dann habe ich am Bahnhof jemanden gesehen, der auch eine grüne Packung Skittles hatte. Und das war auch so ein, ich habe ihm zugenickt, er hat sich beschämt weggedreht, aber eigentlich so ein Moment der Verbrüderung, wo man sagt so, ja, servus. Da kann ich ganz kurz die tolle Douglas Adams-Anekdote nacherzählen einfach. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, aber das ist ein super, ich liebe Fremdkonten, das ist die super Anekdote von Douglas Adams, eine der besten Anekdoten aller Zeiten, auch wie er die erzählt. Und zwar hat er sich Kekse gekauft und eine große Zeitung und hatte halt seinen Hut, seinen Mantel und ist in einem Zug gefahren, irgendwo in England herumgefahren und hat da seine Sachen hingelegt, es war morgens, wo alle Geschäftsmänner auch dabei waren, vor ihm ist ein typischer, ganz normaler Typ, hat sich hingesetzt, hatte auch seine Zeitung, seinen Hut und war vor ihm, ganz perfect, average guy, sass vor ihm und plötzlich legt er fein säuberlich seine ganzen Magazinen, seine Zeitung hin, seinen Hut hin, seine Kekse vor sich hin und plötzlich nimmt der Mann einfach einen Keks vor ihm aus der Verpackung, einfach so und er hat gesagt, er kann das nicht sagen, weil das ist auch irgendwie awkward, wenn er jetzt was sagt.
Und hat dann einfach auch so kommentarlos auch was genommen daraus.
Und der Mann hat dann plötzlich nach einigen Minuten wieder dazu gelangt.
Und er hat gesagt, beim zweiten Mal kann man noch weniger sagen, wenn man es beim ersten Mal schon durchgelassen hat.
Und dann fühlt er dann dazu, dass die Packung irgendwann leer war einfach.
Und irgendwann war es so komisch, hat auch niemand, zwischen dem war so eine Feindschaft, Freundschaft hat sich aufgebaut. Irgendwann kam dann eine Station, der Mann ist gegangen und plötzlich nimmt dann seine Zeitung hoch und sieht, dass seine Packung noch leer war und es gar nicht seine Packung war. Ach nein! Und dann hat, da sagt er, die grossartigen Satze hat dann gesagt, da läuft irgendwo, läuft ein Mann rum mit der gleichen grossartigen Anekdote, nur hat er die Pointe. Das ist ja geil. Nur er, der ist er und hat die Pointe. Der andere Mann. Und dann hatten die auch die gleiche Packung Kekse, oder was? Exakt. Das ist ja geil. Und der andere macht die gleiche Geschichte, nur den Gag nicht am Ende. Der andere Mann kann nichts sagen. Ich hab die Kekse und die Pointe, Bitches. Er hatte noch die Kekse und hat von einem fremden Mann einfach die ganze Kekse genommen. Super Anekdote. Alter. Das dachte ich kurz, bin es Skittles. Warum, was sind die besten Sachen? Er hat die fucking geile Bücher schreibt und dann erlebt er sowas noch. Das ist doch unfair. Oder es ist so eine Art Karma. Oder hat er das gar nicht erlebt. Oder er hat auch die Pointe bestimmt nicht. Er wäre nicht auf die Pointe gekommen,
auf die Pointe zu sagen, ich habe die Pointe
und der andere nicht, und obwohl wir die gleiche Anekdote haben,
da kommst du nicht drauf, wenn du die Pointe hast.
Sondern da kommst du drauf, wenn du die Pointe nicht hast.
Und du denkst, wie geil wäre das jetzt,
wenn ich die Zeitung wegmache und der ist es nicht mehr.
Oder wer ist noch? Keine Ahnung.
Ich denke, der erlebt das nicht, das ist einfach nur lustiger als wir.
Der hat dann diese Beobachtung und begibt es mit seinen Anekdoten aus.
Das ist ein Gier. Wir haben auch schon viele, ey, jetzt mal so rückblicken. Komm, machen wir heute mal eine ehrliche Folge. Du hast ja auch eine Frage, die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die ausgedacht, nicht, aber halt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben. Ja, aber bei dem ist das auch nicht genau so passiert. Der hat bestimmt das Ende, das ist ja auch ausgedacht. Das ist ja auch schon oft vorgekommen, dass sich hier Dinge einfach ... Man verrennt sich ja auch manchmal so ein bisschen. Wir gehen ja auch offen damit um. Wahrscheinlich denkt man einfach, alle haben so ein interessantes Leben, aber alle lügen einfach. Alle lügen. Einfach Lügen. Straight Lügen. Einfach Dinge erzählen, fremde Geschichten als eigene Geschichten erzählen. Das gehört einfach dazu. Ich glaube, alle sind scheiße. Alle sind langweilig. Nur manche können besser so tun, als wären sie interessant. Ich glaube, erst muss die Erkenntnis kommen, ich erlebe nichts, ich bin langweilig, genau wie alle anderen Menschen auch. Und dann daraus kann man so eine, trotz so einer anderen Haltung entwickeln, zu sagen, ich gehe offen mit meinen Lügen. Aber das muss man sich erst eingestehen. Man muss sich erst komplett ausziehen und sagen, ich bin nichts, um dann seine Persönlichkeit wieder von null aufzubauen. Rückblickend war die X-Faktor-Zeit da auch mein Abgrund, den ich geblickt habe, um zu wissen, was man nicht mehr machen sollte. Das Problem ist, du hast ja nie eine vollständige Persönlichkeit. Du begreifst deine Persönlichkeit ja immer gerade noch entstehend. Du sagst ja nicht, ja, heute bin ich fertig. Das heißt, du weißt nicht, ist das jetzt gerade so ein Wachstumsschmerz, das ist ja klar, es geht nicht mehr auf Partys, aber irgendwie, da muss ich jetzt durch, Halt wie wenn man anfängt Alkohol zu trinken, es schmeckt schlecht, aber man muss durch und irgendwann ist es gut. Ja. Aber man weiß nicht, ist das jetzt gerade noch die Phase oder mag ich wirklich einfach das nicht und machst nie wieder. Du hast auch keine Referenz. Du kannst nicht sagen, bin ich gerade glücklich, nicht glücklich, weil man es nicht werden kann? Oder ist es das Maximale, was man an Glück erreichen kann oder kann man noch mehr, kann man glück eine Frage. Man weiss ja nie, ob man glücklicher sein kann, weil man nur sich selber kennt und sein Default-Glück. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ist das jetzt so, also fühle ich mich gerade schlecht, weil das menschlich ist, oder weil ich nicht das mache, was ich will, oder woher rührt das? Ich glaube, es ist einfach auch so eine Angst, was zu verpassen. Ich habe schon so viele Interviews gehört, wo Leute gesagt haben, so, ja, ey, bevor ich Drogen genommen habe, war mein Leben mega langweilig und hey, könnte ich es jetzt rückgängig machen, würde ich es fünf Jahre früher anfangen, weil davor war alles scheiße und jetzt ist alles geil. Und man denkt so, man möchte möglichst wenig solche Momente in seinem Leben haben, wo man sagt so, ey, hätte ich früher angefangen, Saxophon zu spielen, Alter, mein Leben war fünfmal so gut danach. Und da weiss man dann nicht, ist es jetzt so im Moment, hasse ich einfach Saxophon spielen oder sage ich in fünf Jahren, ey, das war das Beste, was mir hier passieren konnte?
Ja. Man weiss einfach nicht. Ach ja. Wir hatten schon lange kein Musical mehr. Oh Gott, ich glaube das. Vielleicht? Kommt es nächste Woche. Hatten wir letztendlich echt kein Musical mehr? Nee, wir hatten, ich glaube in Folge. Wir hatten lang kein Musical mehr. Vielleicht tat es dem Podcast gut. Hängt da von dem Flutter Karibik das Medaillon an der Wand? Das habe ich mir auch... Oh, neue Flutter Karibik-Trailer hast du gesehen? Ja. Überhaupt nicht gefallen. Nee, aber das geht eben bergab mit dem Franchise, machen wir uns jetzt vor. Aber Javier Badem, mit dem coolsten Namen der Welt. Badde heisst der, glaube ich. Javier Badem, Andy Badem, auch der coolere Name noch, Andy Badem. Naja, jedenfalls Javier Badem, Ein Mann wie ein Geräusch, spielt mit, Supertyp, klar, klaro, klaro Kiste, aber macht es jetzt nicht besser in den Film, leider. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Hast du Serienempfehlungen? VOA habe ich angefangen, auf Netflix. Was ist das? So eine Mystery-Serie, ganz okay! Ich habe Westworld gesehen, du hast auch Westworld gesehen. Ja, aber nicht ganz, nicht die letzte Folge. Echt? Ach so, okay, habe ich dich überholt. Du bist immer der Westworld-Experte, hast es einem empfohlen, jetzt habe ich dich überholt. Hab mich verloren. Echt? Ja, kann ich ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Oder? Aber schaut ihr das Ende noch an. Das verrennt sich ein bisschen, ja, okay. Freunde, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, wir wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche. Schaut mal vorbei und schickt uns eure App-Ideen. Wir hauen einen Zwanny raus. Ihr kriegt einen Zwanny bar auf die Kralle. Ihr kriegt in der Post einen 20-Euro-Schein von uns geschickt. Wir schreiben einfach drauf Geldsendung, ich glaube, das ist eine gute Idee, wenn man das macht. Oder in Kleingeld. Kriegt ihr von uns bar auf die Kralle in Schönzwanni für eure App-Idee die beste.
Die ihr dann entwickeln müsst.
Schickt sie uns per Facebook, Twitter oder unter zentrale at podcast-uvo.fail. Die Adresse kann man auch nicht aufgeben. Das ist wirklich die Adresse, leider. Wir glauben das nicht und sagen, ich verarsche mich gerade. Die ist zu lustig, die ist viel zu lustig. Zentrale at podcast-uvo.fail. Meine Idee war noch zentrale at cetera at podcast-gmailorg, aber war leider schon belegt.
Vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze für diese fantastische Folge.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut und wir heben ab mit dem Flordi.